okay more action in Washington DC
yesterday this is from the hill it says
tick tock's Chief Operating Officer
blasted The house's hearing on the
platform Thursday saying that it came
from a place of xenophobia
so it was a hearing on Tick Tock and the
possibility of banning Tick Tock and um
surprising no one
Tick Tock has pulled out the xenophobia
accusation Vanessa Papas who's the tick
tock CEO wrote on Twitter we're
committed to providing a safe secure
platform that Fosters an inclusive place
for our amazing diverse communities to
call home it's a shame today's
conversation felt rooted in xenophobia
thank you to our employees who work
tirelessly to protect our platform and
community
oh yes poor Tick Tock that you know
multi-billion dollar social media
conglomerate is is now a victim of
xenophobia
uh Tick Tock CEO shoesy Chu testified on
Thursday in front of the house committee
on Energy and Commerce as a bipartisan
group of lawmakers grilled him on
concerns of censorship and National
Security regarding the platform
representatives of the social media
platform accused the hearing of being
dominated by political grandstanding in
a tweet on Thursday quote our CEO came
prepared to answer questions from
Congress but unfortunately the day was
dominated by political grandstanding
that failed to acknowledge real
solutions already underway through
project Texas or to address
industry-wide issues of Youth safety
also not mentioned today by members of
the House Commerce Committee the
livelihoods of the 5 million businesses
on Tick Tock or the First Amendment
implications of banning a platform loved
by 150 million Americans
the hearing comes after the buy
Administration demanded the Chinese
owned parent company of tick tock sell
its shares or risk getting banned in the
United States China said on Thursday it
would resolutely oppose any forced sale
of the app
um
so I'm not even sure what the what the
general feeling about this hearing has
been uh in the public I haven't really
paid attention I read just a few reports
about the hearing and I saw some of the
clips and uh honestly I'm not impressed
with anyone involved in this thing
and and in fact uh some of what we heard
there from the the tick tock you know
people is a political grandstanding like
they're they're obviously not entirely
wrong about that the the xenophobia
stuff is ridiculous but
um yeah there was political Grand
there's a lot of political grandstanding
from the from the eclipse that I saw uh
I mean there were moments like this
watch this
do you agree that the Chinese government
has persecuted the uyghur population
well it's really concerning to hear
about all accounts of Human Rights abuse
my role here is to explain what your
platform does it's a pretty easy
question do you agree that the Chinese
government has persecuted the uyghur
population
congresswoman I'm here to discard a
Tick-Tock and what we do as a platform
and as a platform we allow our users to
freely Express ours on this issue or any
other is to the matters to them well you
didn't answer the question
all right um I mean yeah he can't really
answer that question because then uh if
you when he goes back to China you know
we're never going to see him again
um and that's not really like that's not
relevance
at all to the question of whether or not
Tick Tock should be banned in the United
States
uh that has got nothing to do with it
and there were a lot of moments like
that politicians looking for their viral
moments and uh these hearings it's
always that it's like each politician is
taking their turn and they have their
little speech and they're looking for
their moment and uh there were a lot of
moments of um you know they would ask a
question and then the guy would start to
answer it is out no yes or no question
um
you know because they don't really want
an answer what they want is an
opportunity to speak themselves and so a
lot of stuff like that now don't get me
wrong
I'm not defending Tick Tock I mean yes
ban Tick Tock okay ban it from the
planet uh shoot it into the Sun as far
as I'm concerned sounds good to me I'm
on board for that
I guess just call me cynical here I
don't believe
anything will actually happen
um I don't believe that
open proven wrong I don't think I'm
actually going to do anything I don't
think they're gonna ban Tick Tock I
think this is Justin that's all it is an
opportunity for this kind of Showmanship
um and I've seen way too many of these
hearings where politicians take turns
Republicans in particular I mean
Democrats do it too but it annoys me
more with Republicans because you know
they're pretending that they're going to
do something I actually want them to do
and then they don't do it but I've seen
um
too many of these hearings were
politicians take turns you know putting
their foot down and standing up for the
American people and you got these Great
Moments and they go viral look at what
he said and then nothing happens nothing
happens after that
and I get the same sense here uh but
hopefully I'm wrong
but there's another Point too
that much of the hearing was centered
around issues of National Security you
know issues of uh there were a lot of
questions about does tick tock you know
how much access does it have to the
personal information of its users how
much how much information is it is it
you know uh what what are the does it
keep a database of that information all
that kind of stuff and some of some of
tick tock's Defenders
in this country I pointed out that yeah
well I mean Facebook does that Twitter
does that all these all these platforms
do that you know they're all like spying
on us and and saving our information and
selling our information doing God knows
what else with it and that's true that's
like every every platform does that
um it's a greater issue with Tick Tock
because Tick Tock is also a spy app
really for the Chinese government and
that's the problem but
as far as I'm concerned that is not the
primary problem with Tick Tock I mean
the National Security concerns
are major concern
but
for me that's not why I want to ban it I
want to ban it because the app is
terrible for kids
that's what I care about
okay even if they were able to
hypothetically like prove that this
isn't being used by the Chinese
government to spy on us and all that
stuff is above above board and
everything's fine there I mean they
could never prove that but
hypothetically if they did I would still
want to ban it
because that's not my main issue with it
my main issue again is is uh the effect
it has on kids
you know Tick Tock is uh
putting this the spying stuff aside Tick
Tock is a psyop
by the um
communist Chinese to make our kids
stupid and distracted
now we've talked before about I mean
Tick Tock in China is very different
from Tick Tock here
The Tick Tock in China kids are exposed
to educational videos and stuff like
that
um in this it here it's not like that
it's just nothing but stupidity and
filth and uh and and you know loud
noises and uh and and all of bright
lights to distract them and just make
kids Dumber and uh more desperate for
stimulation
um
Tick Tock is not like all social media
does that to kids and all social media
is bad for kids
but
Tick Tock is especially bad just the way
that it's set up
and uh and it's also you know one of the
most one of the most popular apps for
kids
so it's hurting our kids
you know it and that should be enough of
a reason
like there's this idea that we need more
of a reason than that we need to be able
to say more about like it's very bad for
kids
so I can say that
and then the response is well what else
though
and why else should we ban it what do
you mean why else why is that not enough
that should be enough
okay if there were actual uh
constitutional rights in play here or at
Jeopardy
then yeah it's not always good enough to
just say think of the kids you know
um but there isn't what what rights are
are on the line
you ban Tick Tock whose rights are you
infringing on
you're not infringing on the rights of
anyone who uses the the app there's no
constitutional right to use tick tock
and there are a million other social
media apps out there
so whose rights are being infringed on
but
this the Chinese company of tick tock is
that is that who we're infringing on
the Chinese uh whatever it is bike Dan
so the Chinese parent company we're
infringing on there right what right is
that
do they have do they have a
constitutional right to create this app
that's used in America by American kids
so no there are no rights at stake here
um
and so then it really becomes a pretty
simple
to me it's not very complicated it
becomes a really simple question
is this um hurting kids is it
detrimental to the well-being of
children uh yes is the answer and so yes
let's ban it
won't hurt Society like what Tick Tock
is banned
in what way is society harmed by that
okay let's say we ban Tick Tock tomorrow
five years from now
what are the the negative consequences
of us not having tick tock
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block you
become a you can become a member today
by using Code wall should check out for
two months for you on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]